what are some strategies that artists
can use to increase their visibility and
success
are we talking about tasks are we
talking about strategies strategies and
what's the difference by the way
so
the strategy is coming up within with
like the chess moves
you know thinking 20 steps ahead of
where you want to go to or your
competition where it is to get there
the task is
how to execute them
and they're completely different
and so each you know let's just say that
you know it's uh so your strategy is and
I could talk a lot about that because I
had a strategy of how I got my first
movie it wasn't unlucky for me it was a
strategy of what I did and I planted
those seeds for years to get to the
place of getting my first feature film
gig not the perfect gig but I got it
and and it but it created about
thousands of different micro tasks to
get there
I can talk more specifically yeah I'd
like to hear it
so my first feature was wall before
Mickey all right it was
um
the four big stars with John heater Jody
Sweden David Henry and Thomas Nicholas
right
and there is absolutely no reason for me
to take on that director role there are
way more people qualified than I you
know the most I've done was a short film
that wanted this small music festival in
New York City uh I did a few music
videos and I had a wedding company
nothing in there says I should be doing
a feature film with those type of people
about Walt Disney and more the one of
the more American movies that you can
make
and so
but I didn't sell myself as that
director I sold my I sold myself as a
director that had this capability
to uh that that the producers need the
situation that there was another
director got fired right and I was in
the position
where I had branded myself in a way
where there's that I could almost fix
anything I'm a troubleshooter I could
you know I built the business from zero
to a half a million in the year right I
was that type of guy and my peers my
filmmaking peers all knew I could do
that
so I because I knew they knew that I was
going to be in the first in line to know
that I was going to be asked when
something when when they needed help
with something
so that call came in said qua
um there's an opportunity for you it's
about shooting a movie about Walt Disney
and I go what's the catch you know like
because there's no reason to ask me I
said what's the cat they go the catch is
that you have to come down here in a
week and a half no in two weeks
um and you have to be able to start
shooting and then in two weeks after
that so within 30 days you have to start
shooting
and
um
and the the crews demoralized
uh is underfunded
and then they also might be running out
of money for any post-production
so why would anyone take on that gig
everyone would say no to that gig right
why would anyone do that but for me it
was a position it was positioning
because I knew that first of all I knew
that I was gonna I would get those type
of opportunities just because I just
knew that that's how it's gonna happen
but I also knew that if I was able to
fix this movie I was getting more
opportunities
so I said look I told the producers
I'll do the directing gig for 2500 bucks
I'm gonna
it's only a 15-day shoot by the way 1920
piece for 1915 they shoot
and I will take on all the
post-production
I want all the coloring all the editing
deliverable and I will also pay for
yours for the sound mix and the music
I would have completed for you
of course he's going to say yes
of course I think I said everyone's
going to say yes to me on that one so
that was a chess move for me because I
knew that that was an opportunity for me
to take on the right opportunity now it
was a different movie not about Walt
Disney I would have said no because why
waste my energy why waste my time for
that but because it was the right
project it was the one that Walt Disney
I knew they were going to sell that
movie I saw that Facebook had a million
followers already I saw that it had the
stars in place and they had I would say
99 of the crew was more experienced than
me
and the only thing that could have
stopped me was myself saying no because
I was too scared because I wasn't ready
but I felt like I was ready to tell a
feature film story and I felt like
I felt like this was the opportunity
that I was gonna
move my businesses forward and get me to
the next stage of where I wanted to be
so
I took the gig and
um
and within shorts you know long story
short within about two weeks after going
to Market it got sold domestically it
got so internationally it was in Disney
for 12 weeks sold out for four four
weeks straight in at Disney World right
it was an AMC maybe 80 something
theaters AMC it got picked up by Netflix
after it got after it tested the market
it was invested for four years
and still today it still seen you know I
had I had tons of views millions of
views on it not it's not the best movie
but certainly it's not the best movie at
all and I could tell you about uh how
that you know I could tell you why it is
not but it's uh but that was a strategy
and that was a very tactical strategy I
did so strategy and this is a task
that's the long answer
so so many questions here how many
weddings had you done before you stepped
on set
uh we've done 300.
before when you took that that position
okay 300 so you'd been in high pressure
I'm sure there's great weddings and then
I'm sure there's ones that are stressful
whatever maybe the venue's bad or
there's rain or something so you'd
already been in a pressure cooker sort
of environment that's exactly right
right as someone who's worked weddings
before but not just that it was the the
pressure cooker from in music as well
you know
um deadlines the album needs to get
wrapped up you know in the you know you
you're doing a song a day you know
writers coming in and out people are
paying me to get things done blah blah
so pressure has always been it's always
been there you know my college days is
all pressure too and so it's like um
yeah but the wedding for sure helped but
at the time when I took down the gig I
wasn't even shooting weddings I had my
team shooting weddings a lot so it was
more about it was more about how do I
command
that 80 people set
think about it you know there's a lot of
videographers out there but it doesn't
mean they could command 80 people set
um for me I was in a position to command
that just because of me playing baseball
me playing in the music game and then
I'm in the uh and I'm also in the gaming
world and now you said that they were
that the crew was quote demoralized yeah
how did you come in and and Infuse New
Life
um I don't I don't want to you know uh
you know I mean I had a speech with them
and I had told them
that look I'm this new filmmaker and
that you might look think of me as this
this guy that doesn't that that's so new
that might not know what they're doing
but I want you to just treat me with
respect in the very beginning and just
just allow me to allow me to
prove myself to you being really
transparent to them and that that we
were that you guys announcement also
because I talked to them saying that you
guys want to be here if you didn't
believe in the project and we all want
to move things forward as well
so let me do that if you think you and
then if if I could prove to you that I
could build that conference for you that
to believe in me
then I need you to help me finish that
movie
um another thing so that's just talk now
everything is action at that point and
so
on the first after the first week of the
shoot
um the producers and the actors went to
took a private jet to Miami
I was asked to go and I didn't go
instead I took the crew out to dinner
and I was the one that paid for dinner
and I think that was the Saving Grace
for the film because the crew had
issues with production and look the
production team was uh was very new like
producers were new and our respect the
producers a lot right but they were new
and for me I come from from that the
background of understanding how to take
care of people and I knew that this is I
think I'm here to waste my time and I
can't I want to bring home a film and so
in order to do that I got to ensure that
my crew is on board they were just like
a baseball
I work I I want to make my coach proud
I'm the coach of that film crew and I
want the and I wanted them to look at me
as somebody that they want to be that
that I could be proud of them right
and I think uh establishing that
environment was based on my actions and
the first thing I did was I was you know
I'm the first one in on the set I'm the
last one off the set with the PA until
he raps and I do that seven days a week
you know no matter what I'm you know I'm
always just working looking out for
everybody and then
um and then proving it topping it off is
taking out to dinner
and connect with them like human beings
you know and then um you know
um
and so one of the grips he used to work
on The Fast and Furious at the time fast
furious six he says well my guys are
working that tell-off video I never seen
them work that much for you and you what
you said to them resonated and I just
want to just give you a hug and I you
know it's not every day we see that
because usually in film environment is a
very toxic environment sometimes at
least what they're experiencing and so
you guys you seem to make this thing
really fun for us and want to hang out
and there you go
um I hope I could do that it's but it's
not all the time like that because you
know there's a lot of the issues around
it but when they're around me they know
that they could trust me and I got their
backs and as long as they understand
that I got their backs they'll do
everything to protect me
that's great so you came in and was very
you were very transparent and then you
also backed it up it wasn't just talk
you you showed them that I'm kind of
looking out for your best interests as
well you took them out to dinner you
were human with them and it it right at
the ship yeah and you know but you know
that's that's just that's task that's
tactical stuff they have to also believe
in my skill set my talent too right and
so
um one of the first things that
to prove that they could trust me that
I'm going to take care of them and move
this project forward was that they had
to know that I knew what the heck I was
doing on the set
so you know right right on the I
remember the first day we were three
hours late because makeup artists and
costume was late
and so my whole entire storyboard was
out the out the door because my timer
was all off now
and so I said all right we're gonna do
this we're going to do this and we're
gonna have to change everything up and
okay let's just make it happen
and so I reversed you know your your
typical way of doing it your master to
your you know then to your medium to
your close-ups and you have your
structure instead I went the opposite
way I said look we're going to start
with tights and get to the emotional
moment and then we finish up with the
master and we're going to wrap that part
up in three and we're gonna do it in
this three takes and we're gonna save
you guys all this time
did that and everyone was like floored
by how we execute it and right from
there it was like okay business as usual
the way with the trust that I was able
to execute so it was these pockets of
moments where
people it was just humans just test you
to see if you know they just they're
they're this the sizing up and down all
the time and they they're they're trying
to figure out can I trust him
so every single minute every hour had to
be me proving to that crew that I'm
trustworthy to be able to take this film
to the next level and I think that
that's going back to it that's a
strategy
those are strategies because you if you
are thinking if you are the wrong wrong
mindset if you're thinking about it's
about my film they work for me but what
it would it would have failed right from
the first day
and then lastly you talked about doing
post and paying for different things you
had that team in place okay great that's
infrastructure building so people think
like yo what's this wedding videographer
doing on this set like you know if it's
almost sounds embarrassing right
but it turns out that if I didn't have
that in place we would have a finished
film because I have my employees I was
paying them and health insurance I'm
doing I have an infrastructure and the
idea of my my my mindset since 2009 was
to build a team that could support
the opportunities
the opportunity rised and I was able to
support it
that's not an accident
you know I I just knew that was the
Leverage
and I knew that was how I could get it
so because I know tons of people in the
film industry and and they were from PA
to assistant director of all well I
never get those direct opportunities in
producing opportunities
and they they said and I I get the score
still today they said how the heck are
you doing these films why are you
getting these opportunities we've been
in this industry we can't even get these
opportunities to do anything we don't
you can't get a budget to do that how
are you doing that
you know it's like you know it's like
it's kind of like you have to I said
well it's it's it's hot how do I how do
I explain that
right I'm explaining it to you that it
was It Started from the this ground up
but they don't understand that because
they're not business people so for me it
was a mix of business and create a
creativity
like you always look at the big picture
of everything you take on first always
always
um I I look at it as
um
I look at Utopia
I look at building Utopia I look at what
is the perfect world before I'm dead
what is what do I want to see I wanted
to wake up one day and I want to know
that that you know I want to be the
parent that says you know what you know
you might not think about being a doctor
he might want to be a writer because I
think it'd be a better career for you
you know I want that to happen I mean
that's almost like no way no parents
ever gonna say that to that kid
but I do hope that one day that he said
you know what maybe you should be a
singer or a bass player because they're
gonna do you're going to be so much
better off being in that in that career
than being uh being an architect or
something like that you know what I'm
saying it like if you want to decide
that and so I look at that picture and I
do see it happening you know some people
can't see that part happening I do see
it happening and I have this 25 30-year
strategy that's going to get us there as
an industry as a whole at least not at
least I started it or something
so strategies but then the many tasks
that it takes to implement yeah it's
like it's like a hundred thousand micro
tasks to finish one task that's why
she's like one thing at a time yeah